[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
touche
pas quel bonheur ah là là j'ai passé un
weekend oh les gens dans la rue quand il
me voyent les gars il y avait deux types
de gens il y avait des gens quand il me
voyent ils avaient l'impression de
croiser
Merine genre tu vois chaud tu vois et
des gens mais qui me tombaient dans les
bras j'ai eu des regardez bizarre non si
vous n'imez pas mon style n'en dégoûtez
pas les autres pass non non mais tout va
bien non non il y a un problème non
frais tranquille vous êtes là hein oh
fra tranquille pas
mal des gens m'ont appelé des gens de
tout le monde tout le monde m'a appelé
je te jure ils m'ont fait eh tu vois pas
qu'ils m'ont fait du bien les
cons je te jure il y a des gens dans la
r il me disaient on va on vous aimez
bien depuis le complément d'enquête on
vous aime encore plus j'adore et et
voilà je les ai embrassé ça que j'ai
fini dans
dans un troqué
avec une dizaine de personnes et on a on
a refait le match alors beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit ouais est-ce que Delphine Anot
la patron de France la patronne de
France Télévision t'a appelé elle m'a
pas rappelé donc qu'est-ce que je vais
faire je vais la rappeler oui norm
jusqu'à ce qu'elle réponde bah attendez
les gars e oh quand je fais 3 millions
même pas des fleurs ou quelque chose
mais quel des fleurs même pas rien dire
même pas une couronne mortuaire juste un
merci je la rappelle j'ai rien à
dphinne patronne de France Télévision la
grande patronne il y a rien on tout sou
là c'est France 2 France 3 France 4
France haut France France France tout le
monde même France
Pays-Bas c'est parti deuxème sonnerie
bjour vous êtes bien sur vous AMZ direct
sur la M Direct ou je m'en fous je vais
l'appeler tous les jours appué sur
raccrocher l'appeler avec un autre
numéro ça marche pas non plus ah oui ti
Delphine c'est encore c ma Delphine bon
ben j'attends toujours hein 3 millions
c'est pas tous les jours donc écoute euh
je vais te rappeler tous les jours
Delphine je t'appellererai demain à
18h54 voir 55 essayie de répondre qu'on
puisse échanger pour voir les les
modalités de paiement
euh non mais c'est important
[Applaudissements]
qu je veux
bien merci Delphine sinon je Seris
obligé de défalquer du contrat de Nagi
merci je t'embrasse salut dphine bon ben
voilà ça c'est fait non non je suis
content comment ça va vous vous êtes
heureux tiens vous avez pas dit ce que
vous en pensiez
ou V voilà Bernard monel c'est un petit
peu le showe qu'on a pensé le showe le
grand monde du chbiz Ky non plus n'a pas
dit ce qu' en pensé si vous voulez en
dire un mot vous dans un
instant ce
soirie elle fera ce qu'elle voudra qu'
voud aussi n'a pas donné son j'étais pas
là moi oui et galdine doné bien sû
formidable on l' vu ensemble ensemble on
l' vu ensemble avec galdine ah il y a
des préférences c'est bien non pas du
tout c'est que elle me
suivait surtout GG surtout GG tu alors
alors ce que j'en ai pensé j'ai
évidemment regardé ça m' inéressé et
milons et j'ai été extrêmement déçu
parce qu'il y avait rien dedansà mais
qu'est-ce tu croyais qu'il allait avoir
non mais justement c'est ce que j'allais
dire non mais sans rigoler non non mais
déçu par le travail ils ont dit ils ont
annoncé il ans B tu veux que je te dise
mais qu'est-ce que mais qu'est-ce que ça
prouve ça prouve qu'ils ont bien
travaillé ils ont voilà rien mais c'est
moi je trouve ça j'étais j'ai regardé ça
m'a plu et il y a un truc quand même qui
m'a dérangé c'est quand ils nous font
dire commquoi on doit répéter ce que
vous dit c'est un peu AG on va reparler
ça on va reparler on aime bien ça on
aime bien refaire ce débat on peut le
refaire 100 fois on adore ça les chéris
franchement on est lundi on est en
direct et sachez qu'on est bien on est
très heureux donc toi c'est tout ce que
tu as dire ouais rien quoi d'accord
écoute c'est hyper sympa que tu sois
là j'adore quand tu viens vraiment tu
sais qu'en plus je pense à toi je disais
tiel on voit pas assez et tu sais
pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'en plus tes
initiales c'est BM c'est initial de barv
c'est vrai et quand tu viens c'est
toujours une fête non mais c'est frais
je te jure c'est vrai j'adore tu veux
pas qu'on fasse ta bar non je te mets
sur une cha je te lève et tout
s 72 kg quand même 72 kg pas Mali mal
min c'est be2 attends c'est be je m'en
fous un peu voulait direou vous vous en
foutez total alors vous parce que vousz
vous avez dit ce que vous en AZ pensé AM
ou pas du B le truc c'est queon aurait
aimé vous voir bah en fait on on aurait
aimé voir ce qu'on nous a annoncé vous
faire
défoncer et on est dégûé par B é parce
qu'on va rien attendez attendez vous
auriez aimé voir les gens me défoncé bah
c'est ce qui était programmé mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il trouve
bah justement je suis un peu déçu c'est
c'est pas
si érosive que ça votre vie enfin elle
est plutôt tranquille vousêes vous êtes
monotone au final
[Applaudissements]
monotone émission donc vous avez été
déçu mais si vous aimiez bien les
passages mais au final on voit bien que
que bah qu'il a rien à voir et que et
que que vous AZ mis les passages où il
me défoncit bah c'était drôle on s'est
Maré on s'est Maré mais mais au-delà de
ça oui on sait que au final il y a pas a
si ils ont enquêté pendant un an et que
pendant un an ils ont pas trouvé des
choses il
pas à la base est-ce qu'ils vont oser
inventer après il y a des trucs
voilàenté des chroniqueurs par contre
l'toire des chroniqueurs l'histoire de
un gars a dit qui a dit un gars qui a
dit il aime pas ce gars là parce que
truc non mais c'est vrai ça aussi bon
voilà le seul truc qu'ils ont pas
inventé c'est vrai que c'est Kazar c'est
vrai que je l' appelé voilà ça je m'en
suis jamais caché voilàilà c'est tout ça
c'était pas Moné puis les mecs qui qui
qui qui témoignent à visage découvert
déjà c'est plus compliqué de mentir
après un gars qui a dit un autre gars
qui a dit un autre gars qui a dit un
autre gars que j'avais des bassin c'est
bon quoi voilà oui non oui ben voilà moi
j'ai a fait en fait lu
parleou
VO on a couché les enfants et j'étais
très content parce qu'on a pu se
concentrer sur ce petit complément
d'enquête et moi le plus drôle que j'ai
trouvé tu sais c'est quoi cy oua c'était
le micro trottoir qu'elle tu as fait
c'est qu'un moment tu arrives tu es
pressé tu as ton casque tu envie de
partir elle te retient moi trouv que ça
de de très intéressant pour ce qui est
du reste bon que tu manges des burgers
ou que tu prennes un bateau rien à
quoi tu vois c'est ouais c'est
franchement tu fais ta vie c'est bien
l'toire de copilote aussi alors je
m'incris en ah oui c'est vrai vous êtes
le copilote
de que je peux vous dire que si c'était
lui le copilote de mission ce serait
souvent craché voilà c'est pour ça il
disent que B elle sert à rien elle fait
que de rigoler il disent que Kelly voilà
Kelly ils ont parlé cté je pas non je ne
le dirais pas ditesle il a dit a dit ça
a été
dit qui quo la potiche qu'est-ce c'est
une
potiche comment tu comment tu lu
parles mais moi je sers à rien et je ris
et elle c'estit une potiche c'est très
agréableou et non et et eux eux vous ils
ont même pas par vous parce vous êtes
vous êtes le côté le plus nul ça ve dire
la Ligue
2 c'est ça en fait vous quand même quand
même vous ils ont parlé vous eux ils
existent même pas comment tu veux dans
un complément d'enquête qui parle de
TPMP Gilles Verdez n'existe pas c'est
impossible non mais c'est vrai qu'est-ce
que tu as toi sais alors c'est ça ton
problème je te le dis c'est pas ici tu
sais ça va vite avant tu as eu
l'habitude de faire des émissions sur
France Télé où ils sont tourné
complément d'enquête où ça va 2 à
l'heure où les gars ils se réveillent le
matin ils savent même pas qu'ils sont
réveillés ici ça va très vite donc tu
peux pas parler en même temps que les
autres ch sinon tu fais comme ça tu sais
quoi je vais te donner un truc
maintenant tu enlèves ton dentier tu
fais comme ça ah ou et je sais que tu
veux parler ok je sais que tu veux
parler je sais que tu veux parler alors
le chauffeur de salle toujours à côté de
la plaque c'est pour ça que je l'adore
il crie on sait pas pourquoi il a crié
on dirait qu'il avait mal aux dents sur
la tête de ma mère non mais g euh non
mais ça ça veut dire toi tu sers à rien
ils ont dit rien du tout ouais alors
vous avez vu euh on va on va parler 2
secondes de sa marrant moi j'aimerais
bien oui oui allez-y allez-y j'étais
aujourd'hui en train de faire des
courses et j'ai à la cass c'était une
charmante demoiselle avec qui j'ai
discuté parce que voilà et elle m'a dit
oui ça va c'est pas trop compliqué en ce
moment avec ce qui s'est passé avec
complément d'enquête et tout j'ai dit
bah comme tu as vu il s'est passe il
s'est pas passé grand-chose elle m'a dit
oui mais bon il y a quand même un
commentaire qui disait en anonyme que
votre patron il était compliqué alors
moi je lui posé la question et je lui
dis mais est-ce que toi avec ton patron
tu rigoles tous les jours est-ce que ton
patron il t'aide dans tes projets est-ce
que ton patron tu le connais même elle
me dit bah non il est horrible avec nous
c'est compliqué et là tu l' dis bah ça
tombe bien on a le même
patron non mais alors et là tu lui as
dit quoiahah bah je lui ai dit bah oui
c'est c'est un patron comme tous les
patrons donc c'est vrai que parfois il
peut peut être compliqué bah j'ai pas eu
beaucoup de patrons dans ma vie donc je
ne sais pas mais
j'é le patron que vous avez eu plus
longtemps ouais exactement exactement
juste excuse-moi ils ont attendu les
gens et derrière avec leurs cours et
tout là tu parle avec
laa problème en caisse numéro 3 problème
en caisse numéro 3 non après je me pose
sur le côté comme ça mais c'est fort
mais c'est pas mal ce que tu dis alors
moi j'aimerais je vous jure que j'ai pas
j'ai pas prévu la séquence puisque il y
en a plein qui travaillent avec moi ici
s'il y en a qui veulent s'exprimerment
ils ont trouvé le complément d'enquête
ils peuvent venir que ce soit Lionel
quiulent voulez pas vous ne faites pas
voilà même des cadreurs s veent des PER
et des lunettes genre anonym non non non
ils font ce qu'il veul il peuvent
venir même en régie même en régie et
puis même voilà tous ceux qui veulent et
ben ils peuvent venir même même Sora
elle m'a dit non déjà je me fais
insulter non mais allez-y donc si vous
voulez venir n'hésitez pas non mais Mtar
Mar je sais très bien Mar Mar il va dire
c'était une ga mer je le connais par
cœur c'est pur cétait éclaté ouais
éclaté tu dis plus de trucs ici que
cétait nul oui c'est vrai qu'il dit
voilà il il résume bien il résume lonel
tu veux tu veux dire un mot vas-y viens
Lionel ex link Cup maintenant bras droit
de mon bras droit mon bras droit mon
coanimateur un peu parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un peu mon coanimateur parce
que c'est vrai que il fait un travail
exceptionnel lonel je voudrais dire non
mais c'est vrai maintenant tu peux dire
du mal de moi
quandme qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
dise de non mais comment tu as trouvé
dis la vérité franchement après les gens
vont dire ouis c'est franchement claqué
au sol bah il y avait rien ça prend rien
et il y a plus de choses sur le plateau
ici tu tu vois en fait ce qui est génial
c'est que euh ils ont essayé de trouver
des choses que tu dis déjà tu es sur un
plateau tu tu dis tous les jours ce que
tu penses donc je comprends pas pourquoi
ils ont gaspillé de l'argent pour faire
complément d'enquête tu crois toujours
en mon étoile ouais
[Rires]
toujours s'il y en a d'autres qui
veulent venir avec grand plaisir les
chéris vraiment avec grand plaisir et
puis je vous raconter un petit truc là
qui m'est arrivé là ce weekend parce que
j'ai eu des des appels franchement fort
ah
très très fort de la Haute
Instance je peux pas qui mais
toutis estce que la journaliste vous app
complément d'enquête
pour les on tous les jours le service de
presse de France pour inviter trist
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et son
bienvenère qui dit Kelly j'ai eu le même
problème à la caisse du bon marché mais
c'était Marline Chapa j'étais très
heureuse de parler avec elle cière oui
Cère
oui elle était bonne bravo voilà voilà
bon on se retrouve dans un instant à
tout
[Musique]
suite